And four and three and two and one.
Oh,
what a way to lead the show there.
Joe Rogan.
I like to do it that way.
I don't know why I've been talking to
you like that forever,
but I know you will always go into these
Irish accents.
They would throw us out of Ireland with
those exit.
I think it was when you started touring
in Ireland on a regular basis.
That's a long time Joe.
Yeah.
But you,
you've always been touring in Ireland.
I remember you talked about how great
Ireland was decades ago.
Yeah.
You've always loved it there under the
kilkenny festival more than any other
white guy?
No,
I'm an American.
And how long have you been there?
How many times since like 22.
Holy Shit ritual or also in a lot,
but he's.
He's based in London.
I'm the only one that actually still
comes over rich hall for him.
He did this niglet on Saturday night.
Live is based in London now.
Yeah,
he likes it better there.
You know,
he still works here once in a while.
He's got a place in Montana,
but he was on Saturday night live and he
did that snake gluts book and it was a
big smash.
I paid to see him live when I was one
week in the comedy.
He was performing it stitches and I went
there to live,
to sit.
Oh,
in Boston?
Yeah.
So he lives in London now because he's
still doing stand up.
Yeah.
I saw them at the,
uh,
factory in Vegas a couple weeks ago.
Him,
Harris,
Pete and Blake Clark,
he always used Harris Pete,
like he would take care of on the road
with them.
And Harris Peter used to watch is
Montana place for them.
Right.
That's hilarious.
It was a joyless doorman,
like he made the comedy experience tents
and miserable,
but that's pretty funny.
He was,
he was rough as a doorman Harris's,
but he's one of those old staples of the
comedy store,
which is almost kind of weird not having
them around.
Yeah.
I mean he made it so uninviting,
you know,
just have a smile show to people,
they're going to have a good time.
He made it like a military thing.
Yeah,
it wasn't good.
Yeah.
And then there was truly who was always
the guy who was sort of working or
anything you needed from Julie
allegedly,
you know,
he played,
he played guitar at the House of Blues
Across the street and he was really good
years with this group and I was taking
30 feet away.
You're like a Schlub who's like,
you know,
running around trying to,
trying to sell,
you know,
coke or whatever he was doing.
And here you're like a big store.
Like it's so close.
It's so far.
You know,
he used to headline at the House of
Blues.
We would all go over and see him and he
was fucking good man.
Very good.
Yeah.
His band.
Where's he at?
I don't know.
Wow.
I've been seeing me years.
You haven't seen that guy.
And literally forever.
Well,
this whole renaissance to the comedy
store has happened since you came back
and the guys and they started filtering
back,
build burned and Crystal Leo came in,
you know,
but it's been.
When he was here there was some slow
nights,
man.
Oh yeah.
You know what you know,
you know the place is slow.
When polio and I are the most famous
people,
it's not a good sign.
I'm not myself down,
but let's face it,
you need a little more than the two of
us.
Yeah,
it's weird there now,
isn't it?
You go there now it's like it's mom to
contact through the hallways.
It's incredible.
I mean you,
you always think what's going on.
It's nothing.
It's just a regular night,
but you'll have something in the main
room or a Sam Tripoli or that's
incredible.
Tuesday night main room told that was
unheard of.
Yeah.
Tuesday night.
Main rooms sold out while the or sold
out while the belly room and sold out on
Tuesday night.
It's crazy.
It's good though.
It's great for us.
It's fun.
Yeah.
Well I love the crowds.
I mean I really get something out.
It will three clubs.
I really do like factories,
like college kids and,
and foreign students and foreign foreign
people.
And the comedy store to me is the most,
uh,
cross pollinated lake in the sense that
there's so many more tourists because of
the hotels.
You know,
the Improv was kind of like Hollywood
slick.
Yeah.
And then there's the Improv lab,
which I just can't get a read on.
I've done it a couple times just for the
challenge and men,
they sit there and then we'll all of a
sudden they laugh at like scares you
because they were sitting there that was
quiet and then they weird little room.
Yeah.
They're very discerning,
you know,
that.
That's like the hip spot there.
The thing is that room used to be a
great room when it was set up.
The other one,
I liked it the other way to away it was
amazing when it was the whole bar area.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
uh,
I just.
And the thing is,
I don't know if you go,
you don't do the multiple shows.
Oh yeah.
You do them all at the store.
I do some of,
um,
some nights I'll do the Improv,
then I'll jet over to the store too.
I don't really do the factory anymore,
but if I can do it,
if I do an early show at the store,
sometimes they'll do the ice house as
well.
But you'll do benefits there once in a
while.
Yeah.
That's the way build.
Build those,
uh,
two,
it's like,
you know,
whatever makes you happy.
You know,
we've talked about this.
It's like,
wow,
I just loved the idea and I know you do
you have a thought and you can go on
that night.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
What I imagined,
like an actor can't do that.
No,
it's giant too because sometimes that
thought is funny to you right there in
that moment.
You know why it's funny to you and you
might forget why it's funny.
The next day it might have like a little
Napkin with something written down,
you know,
a tampons,
Kleenex,
paper towels.
Well,
I don't carry tampons anymore anymore
because my rectal bleeding and on when I
started,
I don't think that's the way to go with
rectal bleeding.
I think there's other options,
I think.
Did you ever get the colonoscopy?
No.
Colonoscopy,
right?
Yeah.
Anyway,
people ask saying something that goes
funny.
I said,
I don't think these college kids want to
hear about that.
No,
it's not the kind of subject I would
bring up,
but it's bad enough.
I'm older than them.
I don't want to bring up stuff that
hasn't happened to them yet.
Yes.
Stuff that they don't really.
They're never going to understand like
Alzheimer's.
Hey kids,
you know what about Alzheimer's disease,
right?
Disease.
I can't remember the Jamie.
We were talking.
I was telling them the power of this
podcast,
not the stroke.
You be,
you know,
you know how strong it is.
When I went to Australia doesn't not
even think of all these boys were there
and they were like,
busted my chops about not knowing.
How do you remember?
We did a thing about how much does the
gorilla way you were much closer than I
was and they were busted my balls about
not knowing him.
Rogan beat you on that one.
You know that funny can Australia.
Of course it's about wildlife over
there.
I got a buddy,
my buddy Adam Green trees,
always trying to get me to come over to
Australia and every time I find
something online that can kill you from
Australia,
San Antonio,
like,
fuck you.
Yeah,
but you never see that stuff.
You got to go to the outback for that.
Well,
that's what he wants to take me.
Like what are you,
why would you want to go there?
And you might as well just go to the
hobby.
I'm hunting.
It's a lot of bowhunting and Australia.
Bowhunting.
Bow.
Oh,
like archery.
Oh my.
Can you do that in Australia?
No.
Can you do it here?
You.
Are you good with a bow and Arrow for
real?
Yeah,
that's where I got that.
Wow.
I didn't know.
I bonded.
Can't believe I never told you that.
For years I've seen pictures of you and
Brian,
a hunting,
hunting bear and stuff with rifles.
Is that with rifles?
You have any idea how much more of a
manual or than I am?
I'm not thinking about it that often,
but I never.
I mean I don't hunt.
I don't do anything.
To me it's like a big deal to have
somebody drive me to vegas.
I feel like an adventure.
I don't think it has anything to do with
being a man.
Well,
just think you,
uh,
you don't have the same interest as me.
That's the beautiful thing about
America.
Where do whatever the thing you want to
thank you for telling me,
but at the country that we love,
but I just don't.
I don't know.
I mean the whole idea of sleeping in the
woods and all.
It's fun.
I enjoy it.
I enjoy five star hotels.
I enjoy those 24 hour room service.
I like that as well.
That's nice too.
I like that as well,
but I do like getting up,
open up the tent,
looking out and just seeing a mountain
filled with trees and hearing the birds
Chirp and put your boots on.
Happen to a cup of coffee that's warmed
up by a fire.
I love all that.
Must be very funny with you and Kaolin.
Kaolin is one of the funniest guys.
It's amber lived when it comes to like
just hanging out here bullshitting.
Definitely with a small group of people.
You did a time ever zenergy and he just,
he knows how to make shit laugh.
We did this hunt in Montana in 2012.
It was like six or seven days in the
Missouri breaks,
which is like a very,
really a real wild place.
You don't see any people.
There's no cell phone signals and it was
six solid days of gay jokes.
Kona Cowan and I mean gay jokes like
Callan being gay with us,
like wanting to with us are wanting us
to have sex with him and,
and just.
It never stopped being funny.
He's fucking hilarious.
It's now you get all this down.
You just said anybody covered.
Showed some days.
Yeah.
That was for a show that was for a show
called meat eater.
It's say it's a hunting show that my
friend Steve Rinella has.
And um,
we've done that show three times,
four,
four times we've done that show for dms.
Does your wife and going on these trips
like,
no,
she likes it and the meat is amazing,
you know,
come back with wild game hunting and
killing some.
And then eaten it,
so just eaten meat right there.
But the chicken.
Yeah.
But I don't think of it as like a course
because it didn't kill it.
And then do you ever think of like
Salami as being part of an animal?
To me it's just this little thing that
runs around the cut its legs off and
make a sandwich.
Well I think about it that way now I
think about it as meat,
but yeah,
I always just thought about it.
Islam,
it's very convenient.
It's very convenient to think about
things that way.
And you lose that convenience when you
hunt,
you get a weird connection with your
food that um,
some people just don't want.
And I understand that too,
that some people just wanna be able to
go to the grocery store,
pick up a little styrofoam container
that has a stake in it,
take it home,
Cook it,
and they're good and they're fine with
that.
That's fine too.
So you've killed stuff and eating it
there.
I've killed stuff and eating it in the
woods or eating part of it obviously.
And then you freeze it.
Yeah.
Bring it home and phrase it.
When did you start this,
Joe?
Two thousand 12,
so six years ago.
More like five and a half.
And it was a a crossbow or what?
Do you know?
A compound bow looks like a regular
bulb.
It has wheels at the top that are called
cams and then the cams when it turns
over,
gives you the mechanical advantage.
It makes them more powerful.
Good.
It's cool.
It's intense.
I like to cross bows,
but yeah,
those are good,
but it's really just like a shitty gun.
That's the crossbow is to.
Could just shooting a stick instead of
like you're,
you know,
you can rest it and looked through the
like you can put it on a rest.
Actually look through the scope and then
squeeze the trigger like a rifle.
It's not nearly as difficult as a
regular po.
Do you ever shoot an animal?
Hit it,
and then it ran away?
Unfortunately,
yes.
I did that on TV.
I did the mediator show.
Yeah.
There was a problem with the rifle.
The rifle scope was off.
I'd fallen and the rifle,
the rifle scope was installed by one of
the guys.
As we got there,
we changed the scopes because there was
a sponsor of the company sponsor of the
show rather,
and they put a different rifle scope on
and a shot a deer with it and it was
wounded and it was.
It didn't die.
That's kind of suck.
It was horrible.
I mean,
I'm sure it.
Sure it died within a couple of hours,
but we couldn't get to it in time.
Who couldn't find it?
I'd rather just hit it with a car.
Well,
that's one of the problems were where we
were in Wisconsin at nighttime.
You gotta drive slow.
Oh yeah.
They're fucking everywhere.
They're darting out into the middle of
the road.
Especially when it's called.
The rut kicks in.
Red is the deal to get one.
That's what I was thinking.
Yeah.
They run,
they run around,
they get fucking crazy.
They get so crazy.
They'll just walk right into traffic and
just stare at cars.
I'll fuck anything.
I don't know what's coming at me.
I mean there's,
there's videos of Moose trying to fuck
bales of hay during the Rut,
like they literally lose their mind.
They have no idea what's going on.
They were like nine feet are gigantic.
A good size Mousse.
Like a good size.
Canadian Moose could be 1800 pounds.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
You can't even imagine how.
Yeah,
let's try one of those.
One of the other room.
You have Moose Burgers?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I've gotten loose burgers series.
Yeah,
I've got some leftover.
Yeah.
I got a lot of elk burger.
That's an elk that big on the wall back
there.
They're delicious.
So good for you too.
It's like the best meat you can never.
Oh yeah.
It's.
He doesn't even look the same.
It looks like a deep,
dark red.
I don't know how a psychological.
It's obviously like a logical,
but it's certain meats like rabbit I
can't eat and I don't know why because
I'll eat chicken,
but it doesn't really make sense.
Are you a bugs bunny fan?
Yeah.
Big Hardcore hardcore.
Get the tattoo.
Yeah,
but I don't want to talk about it.
Can we talk about the slope,
the airplane to best thing.
I know,
I know.
Yeah.
A lot of people get real attached to
rabbits,
but chickens are like,
they're heartless little dinosaurs.
They're noisy and.
Yeah.
Um,
chickens there are,
you know,
basically a lizard.
The lizard with feathers.
Really?
Yeah.
He pluck all that shit off and look at
them.
Like,
what is that?
What's a bird flying lizard?
Not a good looking animal.
So they know whether or not Tara Dac.
I just found out from my seven year old
the Tara doctors are not dinosaurs.
Really?
Yeah.
She corrected.
They came in a different period.
Oh No.
She told me to not dinosaurs and we
googled it and she was right when I was
like,
how am I so stupid.
Then I was thinking,
you know,
we always had those images,
a Tara Dactyl,
so where they were flying around,
they had like,
like wings,
right.
We've got Jamie,
you got something for me.
That's what it says.
It says that they lived at the same
time,
but they're not actually dinosaur the
dinosaur technically.
Good question.
Somehow they are not actually dinosaurs.
They were flying creatures and
paleontologist keep telling us the
dinosaurs are birds,
so the dye,
what?
Wait a minute,
the petro source,
but that doesn't make any sense because
dinosaurs are birds,
so birds became dinosaurs,
but Tara dactyl who could fly or not
dinosaurs wasn't the bird.
The the closest descendant of dinosaurs?
Yes.
Yeah.
They're not done in source.
So what the hell are they?
Here's the thing,
like when they showed that image of them
with the skin for wings instead of a
bat,
I don't know if they know if that's
real.
I don't know if that's based on what
they absolutely know or like what they
think because they're starting to think
that a lot of dinosaurs had feathers.
Now this is pretty recently I was in the
museum in Bozeman,
Montana.
There's a museum,
like a natural history type museum and
they have like a split image of a
dinosaur,
like a raptor,
and it's covered with feathers.
Wow,
man.
Because they think it's entirely
possible that a lot of the dinosaurs
were covered in feathers,
but I didn't know.
Not as much fossilized remains of it.
I didn't know that.
Men never lived with dinosaurs.
Period.
Yeah.
I didn't know that until a couple of
years ago.
You really didn't know.
I thought cavemen Mino [inaudible].
They always show them like I always go
by the flintstones.
You really didn't know.
Well,
I mean you're a real comic dom.
I guess you don't pay attention to shit
outside.
It's all in jokes like God,
I can do that decently well.
I've had no skills.
I like to teach kids I liked.
I liked teaching fourth grade and that
was about it.
But you like having fun?
Well,
if you teach kids,
don't teach them about dinosaurs.
What did you teach?
I paleontology everything.
I taught everything because it was
Catholic school.
I taught everything but the but the
smart kids math because I was dumb.
I just stuck with the dumb kids and
split the class could come on and you
retards come with me.
Which he couldn't say no.
Yeah,
you couldn't say that.
Now you get in serious trouble.
You'd be on the front page.
USA Today.
You know,
I still have kids that get in touch with
me.
Really?
Yeah.
They said that.
It makes me feel so good that it was the
best year of their lives as far as going
to school because I really,
we had fucking fun.
I would go in my speech was I want to go
to the gym more than you guys do,
so don't mess it up for me and you got
to learn some of this stuff.
I don't know why I hate it too,
you know,
like be like kind of honest.
And they dug it and we had just,
we had dance contest and everything.
It was hilarious.
I had this one kid,
tyrone done.
He was like a baby James Brown.
He could do a split or complete split
and then then get his self up without
touching anything.
Wow.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Like James Brown.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well,
when you're a kid and you're going to
school like anyone who was any spark of
life is exciting.
I still to this day,
think about some of the teachers that I
had in high school.
I had two really good teachers in high
school.
One Lady,
I wish I could remember her name and one
guy who was a Spanish teacher that I'm
pretty sure,
fuck,
one of my friends who was a girl,
she thanks for clearing that up.
He was a young guy.
He was like 25 years old and she was hot
and uh,
I know that they were like talking
lunch.
She was 17.
He was 25.
I'm pretty sure he fucked her.
I'm almost positive she was very
sexually aggressive and she was at
advanced for her time both physically
and mentally.
Like she was one of those girls,
like you knew she was not going to last
in that town.
She's going to get the fuck out of
there.
I remember I did this clean show at the,
uh,
that hotel in San Diego.
The uh,
what was with some,
like it hot was.
It's a clean check del Coronado.
Uh,
I did a clean show,
like an early show at 7:00 on a
Saturday.
They make you be clean.
Oh,
they can only make it be so clean.
But the point,
the thing I was getting at was a 15 year
old boys.
They're right,
and they were with their parents.
They could tell their parents for a
little snooty,
so I said 15,
what a great age and this,
this is good.
This can be a dangerous thing to say.
I said,
you know what's great about being 15?
You can nail a 15 year old girl and not
go to jail for the rest of your life.
And the kids were crying,
laughing,
and the parents were really.
They looked like they wanted to pull
them out of there.
Oh yeah.
Parents don't want kids.
Fucking hilarious.
Well up there both fists.
15,
you really can't get in trouble.
Well,
the girl could get pregnant.
That's no Bueno.
But like the idea that going to stop
them like,
Hey,
you stopped doing that thing.
That feels better than anything ever
going to do at school at work.
Don't do that though.
Your all of your cells in your body are
compelling you in that direction,
but don't do it,
but don't do it.
Your whole body,
your Dna,
your thoughts are haunted.
Everything is wrapped around like ass
and legs and feet and miles and don't do
it.
I remember the first time I worked up in
my bedroom in philly and I came so much
that I thought I'll never have children.
I really did.
I thought I.
I swear to you,
I thought I emptied it.
Take train.
It just kept coming.
Float Gushes in.
Amazing.
How far you would shoot back then to the
distance was insane.
Knock your eye out from.
We googled it and we think.
I think if I remember correctly,
the furthest that guy ever just was like
29 feet.
Holy Shit.
I can't even throw it that floor.
I don't remember making that search.
You blocked it out of your mind,
your memory,
like a childhood molestation.
There was this guy,
Liddy Schultz.
I remember crazy legs.
He used to do a bit of a jerk and he
goes,
I jerk off the midget and he would come
in here and then I went bad.
It's come onto the crowd.
No crazy land.
What do you say to that?
Go.
Good.
I see you're writing.
Always writing.
He used to fucking walk on stage with a
smokey the bear doll and he would.
He would hold the dollar up and say,
only you can prevent forest fires,
and he goes,
shut the fuck up and punches me.
Kenny said you were crying,
laughing.
He was one of those guys that was just
fucking funny.
From the look on his face to everything
he said.
He just knew how to.
He was his own unique style.
You just knew how to be funny.
Well,
he had that psychotic.
Funny too.
Like he looked like a guy who would
pettit pigeon go,
yes,
sure.
Daddy loves you and the now what did I
do exactly what?
They loved you crazy.
And then chuck it aside and moving on
with his act.
He grabs the pen only you can prevent
forest fires.
Shut the fuck up punches.
We remember Jimbos place in Montreal.
Yeah,
of course.
Where we were.
That's where we saw crazy.
Lenny will was probably around the first
time I met you then.
Probably.
Yeah,
like 93 ish.
Somewhere in that range.
I remember meeting you at the club Soda.
Yeah.
That was fun.
And then we ran into each other again at
Amsterdam billiards pool.
There's only a few of us to play the
pool already.
Lange plays real good.
Pool does a very good.
Fitzsimmons was here yesterday.
He plays real good.
Greg and I just played at the,
uh,
at the Improv.
They used to have a quarter table
upstairs.
Oh really?
Yeah,
for hears.
Oh,
the set up up there.
It's very nice down now.
That whole green room with the,
the,
the uh,
podcast studio.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Very nice.
It's a good setup.
We're plugging the shit out of these
clothes,
but yeah,
like at a guys who play pool I comics
and play pool.
It's a fucking small group of us.
Yeah.
Not that many.
Who else?
Somebody else plays good.
I think a man Adam for a place for our
police.
Very good place.
Very good.
Yeah.
He was at my house playing,
but I know a number.
Get you back there because there's too
many obstacles.
Kind of Jack Up have one of those little
baby cues.
Well Joe,
who has room like this,
who has 50 feet on each side of a pool.
Well,
we're going to stream some stuff from
here.
We're gonna eventually stream pool
matches.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We're going to set up cameras and just
talk shit and have a live stream.
You ever heard of twitch?
Do you know what twitches twitches?
A streaming service where you play games
on it?
Mostly video games.
Most people use it for video games,
but we've been talking to them about
doing video games and then I'm thinking
we might do some pool matches as well.
And even some archery put me up against
Tosh.
Alright.
You go to play a little bit,
but I just,
I always beat him,
you know?
Oh,
just logical advantage.
I don't know.
I love beating him that.
And then shooting baskets because.
Because it calls me old man,
grandpa and all this shit.
So I want to beat him in something.
Uh,
you know what I'm modeling some of the,
what I do after Tosh in that he doesn't
do any interviews.
He's like,
can I do enough?
So fucking smart.
He's so smart.
He's like,
he knows how to not be overexposed and
I've,
I've fucked that up in the past and now
I just like when I get here,
might get requests for interviews.
I'm like,
what?
I've said I say too much already.
I'm already talking to you.
Notice I never asked you again because
he did me the favor and I don't want to
push it,
but the fact is we had Jamie to fuck
around with that time.
So No,
I will,
you know,
I'm not going to really nail you on an
interview.
Make you.
What do you mean on your pod?
Yeah,
that's different.
I do friends podcasts at the time,
but it's,
I'm like interviews and real show,
stuff like that.
It's like you got nothing to gain Joe.
You're famous enough in Daniel's,
right?
I mean,
what,
what are you going to get good out of
that?
Like doing Jimmy Kimmel doing five
minutes.
You probably wouldn't want to do to
stand up even though that your favorite
thing and then you go over to the panel
and like,
I like Craig Ferguson only because it
was improv.
Right,
right,
right.
Well,
I think that sitting down and talking to
someone should be like this.
You really,
really,
really want to get to know somebody.
Yeah.
She talked to him like this.
Have I have a real conversation with
them having a conversation with someone
when you're under the gun of five
minutes and you know,
there's a band there and you're sitting
sideways and you're at the desk and I'm
sitting over like this and you know,
we're talking about some project that
I'm doing.
He eats like a quick pitch.
You have like a quick story that you can
tell.
And just so I understand your rent a car
when you come into the town.
What's that like?
That's funny.
Dumb,
you know?
Uh,
I do rent a car and I always take the
insurance,
you know,
why?
Because I drive like a fucking maniac
and New People here on highway 95.
What do you know,
what is going on with the drivers and
last turn to the audience?
You know,
Ferguson show once and he gave me the
wrong plug.
I was,
I had already worked that,
you know the Denver Club that you like
so much comedy works.
Yeah,
I'd already worked at and they plugged
it in and I said,
you know,
I came in,
I said,
Craig,
you got to really crack stamp here.
I already worked at Gig.
I said,
but I'm so hot.
I'm white hot in this business.
They have to post plug thing so there
won't be a riot.
They said,
well,
we'll just start it over because they're
filming it.
I says,
no,
I didn't.
I got a spot in a couple of hours and
he's starting it over and we got like
an,
a fake argument.
It was the most fun I ever had doing the
live standup because I.
So let me go,
go sit in your high chair and judge me
like a little joke monkey and then I'll
come over and we'll say funny stuff
there too.
Well he's just doing stand up now.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's on Sirius too as well.
Yeah,
but just got tired of doing this show
was in his name.
Hitler or something or really?
I think so.
His name is Hitler.
Craig Ferguson,
what kind of Asshole for a parent if
you're born with the name of Hitler?
I don't care how far you get away from
that.
I can't remember the whole name,
but I think Hitler was in the.
In the name.
The name,
like Hitler's Berg.
Butler Stein.
Scottish,
right?
Yeah.
What is it?
It says Bang Hitler.
It was like the eighties looks.
Yeah.
Oh,
being Hitler.
Was it a character that he was doing?
Yeah.
Oh,
I wish we could play it.
look at him.
That's hilarious.
He's 12.
He looks like he's a kid in school.
Really the young face is with is fake.
Act was hair all fucked up.
Give me some money.
Wow.
That accent.
So it's so much thicker in it.
Wow.
From Mexico.
So he a character that was the character
that he'd do and the character,
he would go crazy with it.
Well,
there was a time and they're still.
Kala is still a time where we're in
throttled by mediocre people with fake
accents.
Not fake accents.
Accents from other places.
Foreign accents I should say.
Not fake.
It's like the thing that bothers me and
I love standup and it was when a guy act
so different or like all of a sudden he
goes into this character,
you know what I mean?
Instead of the funniest guys to me are
guys that do characters but the
themselves.
Yeah.
And they talked real like,
you know,
and that's why I mean you and burn you
were the same guy as on and off stage.
You know when we're talking sometimes
you get silly.
Sometimes you're serious.
You just be yourself.
Yeah,
I know what you're saying.
Be Sincere,
but you can be just as fucking goofy as
you want,
but don't stay in that so hacky to me it
can be.
I'm always waiting for someone to do it.
Right.
So I don't want to pass judgment.
Like maybe one guy comes along and he's
in character all the time,
but it's fucking hilarious.
It's possible.
I just watched jim carry on when he did.
Andy Kaufman.
Yeah,
it was fucking amazing.
Oh,
that was that the documentary?
That was.
Yeah,
that sprang sprang from that,
but I was watching the movie last night.
I forget what it's called.
A man in the moon.
Yeah,
man on the moon.
What?
Jim's good.
Oh,
it's brilliant.
You know what's really interesting with
him,
he's taken like a severe,
um,
psychological and philosophical turn
where he's,
he's just thought about life and things.
So he must've had some psychedelic
experiences too.
I think.
So.
Sounds like it.
Yeah.
Because he's just talking about what
matters and what doesn't matter and you
know,
and there's a bunch of interviews and
uh,
clips of him discussing things where
you're like,
whoa.
Like this guy does not.
He's not talking like Jim Carrey,
the world famous,
a list actor who's had gigantic smash
movies.
He's not talking like that at all.
He like talking like some guy who's just
trying to sort of understand his place
in the universe.
Yeah.
He's really,
really profound ways.
Very well thought out.
God.
Thinking about him painting now.
It came out a couple months ago.
We didn't,
we play this where some of his paintings
are really cool.
They're like a neon and he talks about,
he says some of the stuff that he's been
thinking about and dealing with.
So it's called,
I need color and it's on Vimeo.
So folks can check that out.
I tell you about the below part.
I have been dying up here.
No.
Okay.
So I play fitzy Anderson because they
wouldn't let me use Fritzi Anderson.
Remember 15 innocent?
No,
it's just they go on.
Hello?
Yeah.
And they wouldn't let it parents.
Why wouldn't they let you.
They said Fritzy was a slur for two
Germans flats.
Yeah.
So anyway,
I go into the comedy store and a
Thursday night,
why was there just to practice.
I know like real trying a couple lines
and doing some shit.
And Jim's in the audience.
It comes out,
he hugs me.
And Anyway,
long story short,
he,
he was with his wife,
his ex wife,
and their daughter was ill,
a great girl.
She's a really good singer too,
by the way.
But anyway,
uh,
they started talking and he said,
wow,
fucking funny.
Dom,
was she going to.
He goes,
I want to put them in this show.
And Melissa goes,
will tell you one thing.
He's not going to dance for you.
You want them to ask him,
but he ain't gonna audition it because
I'm not going to make an addition.
I've known him for fucking 30 years
anyway.
That's how I got the part and that
funny.
Just randomly,
randomly he was.
He came in to look for young comedians.
I am not one of them.
We could tell by my receding hairline,
but yeah,
I mean an amazing.
I mean just there on the Thursday night
randomly.
Is that show still going on?
Yeah,
we're shooting a shooting 10 more.
I got A.
I know I'm doing.
I'm an alcoholic,
an alcoholic the whole time,
which was.
I never watched it.
I watched one episode and I thought it
was pretty good,
but I heard that it got better.
Yeah.
I heard that it was improving.
I heard.
Well,
you know all of those things.
Do you remember Seinfeld at the
beginning?
I remember news radio.
The show I didn't.
Yeah,
it was clunky.
It took a while to really get rolling.
Yeah.
To get the rhythm.
What it is,
sitcoms are very difficult.
You know what I mean?
One of the reasons why people are like,
oh,
bonds,
there are any good sitcoms in the air.
Well,
God damn,
it's hard to do.
Well,
this is the serious one.
Like I'm kind of the comic relief on
this because it's about like comedians
but not like,
you know,
when we goof around,
Hi Parag and these llc,
hardly any of that.
And you see them more like jealous of
each other and they're still in the dark
side of it.
The woman who plays the Mitzi part is
Melissa Leo.
She's an academy award for some boxing
movie.
I forget.
Uh,
but she,
she's playing Mitzi really serious and I
don't want to say anything because she's
a great actress,
but if I were a to give one note,
I would say they were.
Mitzi really had a fun side to her
missing,
by the way,
for those of you who don't know is,
was the owner,
the owner of the comedy store,
pauly,
shore's mom.
She brought us two things.
One of them was awesome.
Just kidding.
Has he been on the show?
Yeah,
he's been on.
Yeah.
I like Paulie.
He's a sweet guy.
He's a good guy to be around.
I keep giving people hugs and cit in,
in like all of us trying to.
Yeah.
Well he,
he had a hard life.
I mean he imagined being Babysat by Sam
Kennison mean.
What in the fuck kind of crazy shit.
Is that Erica?
Sam Walton snap with your mom.
August Sam kinison hanging on your
house.
Everybody's doing blow and you're going,
what?
The city.
It's so huge.
Gigantic at one point in time.
Who?
Sam?
Well Sam was for sure,
but.
So it was Paul Quality.
Yeah.
Paula was gigantic to.
Was it the weasel mean when he was doing
movies like in the army now with Andy,
Dick Number that Jesus Christ is huge.
We had a three picture deal and encino
man.
I was another one biodome memory to
biodome with Stephen Baldwin.
It was a good movie.
I enjoyed it.
Don't look at me like that.
Suddenly hire some people,
talk about them all the time.
He's fucking funny.
Those movies were fucking funny.
I don't know what he did wrong or where
it went wrong or you know,
sometimes it's like,
I think people just get bored.
They just want some new person.
Right.
Who's hot right now is tiffany haddish.
Oh shoot.
Do I love the curl?
You Ju Ju Ju?
She is.
I was trying to say Jewish by the way.
Is She?
Yeah,
she's Ethiopian Jewish.
No kidding.
Yeah.
Tiffany haddish is the person who told
me about sickle cell anemia being
related to malaria.
That people who have a resistance to
malaria developed the trait for sickle
cell anemia.
Wow.
That's where the origins of it are
apparently.
And that's crazy.
It's primarily a Jewish and a black
disease.
Is it a Jewish,
uh,
diseases and blacks get it than any
other,
other.
It's interesting.
I did not know that.
I thought it was just blacks.
I had a friend of mine died from it.
Yeah.
My friend Walter.
Yup.
I'm from back.
Uh,
one of them was fighting who,
uh,
I remember it.
I would love to see if like I was a
different guy.
Man.
I was very intense.
I wasn't a very fun.
Did you ever think you'd be a comedian
when you were in those days?
No,
I didn't think I was funny.
I made people laugh,
but the people that are made laugh,
we're all psychos.
They were all like guys that I was
training and fighting and I was just
like.
I felt like we were all freaks,
you know,
because we were martial artists that
were traveling literally all around the
country and entering into these full
contact tournament's.
You don't have any video.
There's a video of me on youtube really
knocking somebody out.
Yeah.
When I was 19 and Connecticut.
You think you could beat me in court?
No,
I couldn't.
I love you too much.
I just hold you.
Well,
you know what you do,
which is really interesting for a guy
that strong.
You never know right there.
Doesn't mean the blue like kicked that
guy in law school.
That's all.
I have some other video on my computer
somewhere.
Some like uneventful round of some
taekwondo tournament.
There's a guy out there has got a couple
of videos made though and he and I've
gone back and forth.
On what way were you?
That was 1:54 when I was in senior year
in high school.
I fought at 1:40 and that was too light.
It was too hard for me.
I was always dehydrating myself and I
would uh,
like uh,
do things in the shower,
like jump up and down in the shower and
shadow box and the shower with the hot
water on and try to sweat out weight.
I couldn't eat for like a whole day and
then I would fight that day and it was
terrible.
I did that for one year.
Well my father was a professional boxer
and he,
uh,
but he was the bad thing about it.
He was a $500 bucks or oh no,
box 500 and baseball.
You the greatest player ever,
but boxing you,
you got to be like 800,
you know,
at least make a living.
When he won,
he would come home and beaten up.
That must have been hard to see.
I'm all fucked up.
You.
I see people that fight in the UFC and
their kids come to hug him in the cage
and you know,
you see the terrified look in their
children's face and they're looking.
The guy's eyes all fucked up and got
some different group or different type
of human being that does that.
I had so much fun though.
The time you invited me to the one in
Montreal where the guy who's the king of
Montreal was George St Pierre.
That was incredible.
It was the loudest noise of cheers I've
ever heard.
They love him.
And the other one was when we went to
the places that were those guys who own
the Sacramento Kings,
the,
the plate with the playboy club.
And you had fights there.
You know what I'm talking about that
it's off the strip.
The Palms?
Yes.
And one of the cool moments,
I mean even though he realized how
powerful and how real it is,
this kid got knocked down.
I was sitting next to his mother and his
wife and he wouldn't wake up for a
couple minutes and then he finally got
up,
but then there was another kid who was
like in the cartoons.
He ran up the wall and I don't know how
the fuck he did it and he just is young
black kid.
He ran up the wall and went upside down
and then landed on his feet.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
John Dodson is pretty sure it was young
males that after fights he runs up.
Yeah.
He's a freak.
Awesome athlete.
Yeah.
That's a different kinds of human being
that does that.
It's to be in that world that's a.
that's a pool to send an intense
existence.
That's unlike very many other this in
this war.
Other than war.
You know,
war is probably the most intense
existence.
Guys who are warriors?
Actual soldiers.
Other than that,
I think mma fighters and then obviously
first responders,
firefighters,
cops,
things on those.
Oh Man.
I was thinking about that with those
fires this year.
Oh God.
My Body's a firefighter.
He was up there and now he's in Simi
Valley and they shipped him out with
everybody else and he tell me it was
insane.
He's like,
you,
you just,
you couldn't stop the fire.
It was just too big and there,
you know that thousands of firefighters.
And here's the other thing,
not just thousands of firefighters but
prisoners really.
They had prisoners working the fire.
They could get out early,
baby.
I don't think so.
I think they got paid and I don't think
they got paid much.
I think the unpaid,
like a dollar an hour,
something fucked up and they're out
there working on the fires.
I'll just pretend I got burned.
Just run into the fire.
Wow.
I'm free.
I got a fake Id.
I'm going to Mexico.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm pretty sure they did.
I think that's one of the most fucked up
things about prison is that they get
them to work and they pay them like
pennies.
I didn't know that.
I mean,
I know they get them to clean up or even
if you have a dui you can get that and
that won't even go into prison.
Yeah,
right.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah,
you can,
when you can work it off or pay it off,
clean the sides of roads.
A friend of mine did that instead of.
He didn't have the money.
How much is the money to Pay Dui?
Uh,
I think it all comes around 10,
10 grand.
Met with the lawyer and everything been
granted.
A dollar an hour is a long time.
Oh my God.
If they really pay a dollar an hour.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
like at the Dui,
just use uber it now.
Most of the time,
right?
Yeah.
I drunk right now.
No.
Do I look joke?
That would be sad.
I get nervous when I talk to you.
We've been friends for 30 years almost.
Holy Shit.
Not Crazy.
We've been friends for 25 years,
somewhere in the neighborhood of 25
years.
That's a long time.
Mr Herrera.
That's crazy.
Nut nuts.
Do you think I'd have more material by
now?
You've already used it off.
Hey,
are you a,
you're talking about filming something?
What do you mean?
Are you talking about filming a special?
You know what?
I did one last time.
I was on the show you told me I should
do when I did it and I just didn't like
it.
Oh,
when did you do it?
I'm not,
whatever.
The last time I was on the show,
it's like a year ago I would imagine a
little more.
And then I waited about three months and
I shot it.
And uh,
you just said not to release it?
Yeah.
What was wrong with it?
Like what didn't feel good about it?
I don't know.
I just didn't my ass look fat.
I just didn't like it.
I didn't.
It didn't seem to have the energy I
thought I have,
you know.
Huh.
So it didn't feel to you like
representative of a real set that you
would have?
I got a just a normal night at a club.
That's all I wanted.
Did you feel pressure?
Because that's one of the things that I
feel that I've always battle when I do a
special is that like here's the moment
it's now ready.
Go.
And one of the best ways I found to
combat that I was to do a bunch of shows
I do for chefs.
See,
that's smart.
I did two.
Yeah,
two is tight and they were back to back.
Yeah.
Sometimes people clam up.
I've seen people do one and it becomes a
disaster.
You could feel the tightness on stage
because there's so much riding on it,
but it's just not just a regular show.
There's no room really to fuck around.
You got to have room to fuck around.
Like part of what a live show is is
flowing.
I mean I would like to get myself in a
club where I'm half once,
like if something's worth talking about
with the audience member or something
that's really cool,
I would do it.
But just being normal club set that's a
little more normal but very strong club
set.
Where did you film a.
The laugh factory in Vegas.
Yeah,
that's.
You remember that.
So you still laugh factory in Hollywood.
That's a comfortable club for you and
they already set up for filming.
Yeah,
I know.
I could do it any night.
Yeah,
maybe that's a good move.
Well Jamie one that had taped me like a
couple of weeks in a row doing like 40
minutes.
You know,
you should,
that's a great place to do it,
dom,
because they filmed me.
Whether you like it or not there.
Yeah.
Well we talked about this.
That's not a good sign,
but they do have the setup.
They have the setup to film you there.
Vegas Room is nice,
isn't it?
You know,
is that a trap?
That's.
Here's the thing that's great about
Vegas,
Joe,
is that you could do that.
I'm doing the first week of April.
I think the trop dental do Brad Garret
club too because they don't give a fuck.
It's Vegas.
Vegas.
I'm like Columbus,
Ohio.
They have the same audience pretty much,
you know.
But uh,
they're,
they have the audience comes in from far
away every week.
So you could play Vegas a lot.
That is true.
Like that's one of the reasons why
residency works in Vegas.
Always anywhere else.
Have you ever thought about doing that
residency?
I think,
well,
I think I killed myself in Vegas.
Just boozing and yeah,
hanging out and the rhino at three in
the morning.
Fistfuls of dollars.
Dat,
dat type.
I go out with this girl and she got
really hot daughters right when she shot
the girl you're dating and she's very
hot,
but she's always telling me how
beautiful her daughters or I go,
look,
I know,
but I don't watch step.
Stop pimping off your daughters to me.
But I took.
I took him to see tosh.
I was in the town for the superbowl and
Daniel was at the mirage and it gets,
I forget how big a deal it would be to a
16 year old boy to meet him.
And we went back and he was saying he
was so gracious with them,
but it was,
I couldn't believe it because this kid
played John Lennon in loves it when he
was a little kid.
So he's got.
He's been around theatrical people,
you know,
love the Beatles.
That needles thing is fucking amazing.
Good at the Mirage.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They started that acapella because it
was very cool.
I know you're a huge Beatles fan.
Yeah.
You've always been a big beatles fan.
So I,
I took my family to see that about a
month ago or so,
went to see that the Mirage.
Fuck.
It's incredible.
It's such a showman and it cool to see
your kids kind of digging it.
Yeah.
Get all those years ago.
And you know,
I know so many little kids that liked
the Beatles.
It's weird.
They're so good.
They were so good and you.
And I think it's hard for someone today
in 2018 with this vast variety of music
that we have and so much good music over
the history of music,
you know,
so much recording that it's hard to
understand how in the 19 sixties how
amazing the Beatles were.
Then out of nowhere this band out of
Liverpool comes out and they just have
this revolutionary music.
It's just so much of it is so different.
Yeah.
It was very different and they were the
ones they orchestras and all this stuff,
you know,
it reminds me of the,
uh,
the thing we were talking about before
of the sitcoms.
They were given a chance to get better.
A lot of people today,
if they,
if they're bad records,
they're out and they got some other
beautiful girl replacing them.
It's true.
You know,
it's the same way with fighters.
I've had this conversation with my
friend Brendan Schaub and I were talking
about this the other day,
but yeah,
big brown guys get into the UFC too
young and then they're fighting top
flight competition like right away and
it's either sink or swim and some guy
swim,
but some guys have real massive
potential,
but really they should be fighting
someone of a lower caliber and
developing their skills and experiencing
a bunch of different styles and then
eventually working their way up to the
UFC after five,
six years or so and instead they're
fighting in the UFC at 20 years old and
they're just not really ready for top
flight competition.
[inaudible]
in the UFC,
if you string together five,
six wins,
you're entitled contention some weight
divisions.
Yeah.
That'll discourage the shit out of you
and you're getting fucked up by some guy
who's just many,
many levels above you.
You really shouldn't be fighting him.
Like the flyweight division is perfect
example because it's run by this guy
demetrius mighty mouse,
Johnson's probably best pound for pound
fighter that's ever lived and he's
saying something,
man,
he's fucking incredible and he's a
wizard,
like he barely gets hit and you know,
and we've seen him in the octagon
develop and grow and become this guy and
now now he's just just,
uh,
there's everybody.
And then there's mighty mouse.
Mighty mouse is just another level above
everybody.
I never seen anybody as good as
mayweather to avoid punches.
No one's better.
No,
no one,
no one gets hit less.
It's incredible.
I mean guys 50,
you know,
and obviously one of them was conor
Mcgregor,
which is kinda crazy,
but it connor hit him,
you know,
connor can crack,
but he just didn't had no business in
the ring.
Honestly.
Maybe we really didn't know if he had
business in the ring until he fought
them after the fact.
It's easy to say that.
Like he caught him with that upper cut
in the first round.
What if we wobbled them?
What have you heard?
Anybody can get crazy if you get hit
right.
Anybody can get knocked out,
but may whether it's been hit right
where he was hurt.
I don't think conor hurt him.
I think he just hit him good,
but he's been her sugar.
Shane Mosley heard him.
He's been hurt a couple of times in his
career,
but over the course of 50 professional
fights where most of them are at world
championship level.
It's crazy remarkable.
I was watching the.
They had like a highlights of the MMA
and the when Fox today and Rhonda Rousey
when she got kicked in the face though.
What a great kick that was.
Holly Holm?
Yeah,
that was in Australia.
I remember being there for that.
Oh,
that was a Melbourne,
right?
I think it was in Sydney.
It wasn't.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure.
Sydney.
That was crazy.
It might've been Melbourne.
You might be right.
Might be right.
I think you're right now that I think
about.
I think you're right.
No,
you're definitely right.
Now that I know I'm stop.
Bargain with yourself.
Leave yourself alone.
You're a good person trying to remember.
I love Melbourne.
I love that great restaurant.
It was just going to say that great
coffee to Donovan's.
They have everything like their seafoods
fantastic,
but it's almost like I'm an artsy sort
of San Francisco.
Yeah,
San Francisco's the one I compare it to.
but it's got its own thing.
Yeah.
Melbourne's got its own thing.
Fucking crowds are amazing.
Oh cool.
And so fun.
Yeah,
they're great up there.
I did a comedy store in Sydney in
between like bigger gigs that takes to
make it worth it for them to bring you
over them and I love it.
I love the culture and the of data to
Ari and I did the comedy store in Sydney
on a Sunday night on a whim.
The fights took place early in the day
so that it could be in the UFC pay per
view,
so we called up the comedy store and
said,
Hey,
can we do an impromptu show tonight?
We'll just put it up on twitter and they
said,
all right,
hold on,
let me call you right back.
All right,
we do it.
Let's do it.
And so we put it on twitter and then Ari
and I went and did a show that night.
The kid.
They came.
Yeah,
it was packed.
Yeah.
It was awfully heavy draw like you
helped me get a drone in Australia and
that amazing.
Crazy.
Yeah.
I mean when I was,
when I started.
Now if you get on the tonight show,
that would be the first time hole all of
America.
So you get the whole world not like
this.
The whole world hears this.
Yeah.
This thing has got its own life.
I remember that.
I'm just here working the wheel.
I was at your house one day when kind of
like you had started it,
but you said you feel,
forget what the exact word,
but be a momentum going when you felt
you knew something was something
incredible was going to happen with this
show.
Do you remember that?
Well then you just had the.
You told me you have a feeling like you
weren't bragging.
Not at all,
but was just like going with the energy
of it,
you know.
Well,
I was,
I was saying that I felt like there's
something going on.
Yeah,
like this show,
like it was just starting to pick up
momentum then and I was like,
there's something going on here.
And then I was thinking about what the
potential was and at the time when we
first started,
there wasn't that many people listening
to podcasts.
It was very small and uh,
we were also streaming live on youtube
ustream and there wasn't many people
listening to that either or watching
that,
but I was like,
but this keeps growing and I,
and I knew that I was very interested in
doing it,
so I knew I was going to get better at
it and I was always trying to figure out
what,
what ways I could do it better,
how to get out of my own way,
how to not talk over people,
knowing when to talk,
when not to talk.
I had to figure that out.
It's tricky.
It is tricky.
It's tricky to um,
to pay you.
You have to put yourself in the seat of
the person that's listening.
And I think listening to podcasts helps
that as well and listening to things
that you don't enjoy.
So he's.
One of the things that Stephen King
always says about writing is that you
should.
Right.
But you should also read,
you should read a lot.
I think that's the case with podcast
too.
I think that's the case with standup as
well.
I think listening to other standup is
good as long as you're not getting ideas
from them,
you know,
as long as you're just enjoying it.
Like the good feeling that you get from
watching stand up watching someone kill,
you know,
it's like I get inspired by it and it
makes me.
And then I see things,
maybe they're a little clunky in
someone's act,
like how they need to clean that up or
tighten this up.
And it makes me more cognizant about
those flaws in my own act and makes me
more,
more self aware.
I love to watch like say like Chris Rock
when he does something and then two
weeks later we're,
you know,
he's got a germ of something there,
but he's so good at putting it,
you know,
setting it up to be a potentially really
great bit,
you know?
Well,
he's one of the all time greats for a
reason and one of the reasons is he's a
real craftsman.
He's a real artist.
You know,
Chris will go in there and he will.
He's not just trying to kill every time
he goes onstage,
you know,
he's,
he's trying to develop material and he's
using that time and it is a very
valuable thing for him,
you know?
Well,
I,
I really believe that this generation is
better than the generation I started
with and only because they got to see
them and grow from them.
You know what I mean?
Like you had to have somebody in the
middle because I mean honestly,
you know,
you and bill to me,
I take you and bill over prior and the
Carlin,
that's sacrilege.
Serious.
I stand ups.
But,
you know,
and I'm not saying that because you're
my friend and when we're here,
I'm saying I,
I seen these guys and I loved,
I loved them,
you know,
I mean,
I was one of those kids who grew up
watching him,
but I think it just is this,
your generation has taken it to a
different level.
There's a,
there's definitely a benefit of being
able to see the people before you.
For sure.
I've,
I've learned a lot watching other comedy
work,
watching people just getting,
you know,
we were talking yesterday about Richard,
Jenny,
that um,
I think I'm brilliant writer.
Oh,
you're so good with him.
I said,
man,
with sandals,
I think of him say,
Hey,
you're doing this.
Spartacus.
Yeah.
Um,
he,
uh,
I was listening to one of his recordings
on the way home.
A big steaming pile of me,
like a,
I don't know,
at least a year ago.
It's probably more,
but I remember like getting a noticeable
bump in my writing after I listened to
it because it was so inspiring and that
I think that's a giant advantage that we
have today with like youtube and itunes
and things along those lines where you
can listen to anything you want.
I can go back and I was listening to an
old woody allen recording the other day,
just in my car driving.
Now listen to Woody Allen,
do standup in the 1967.
You could tell he was a fucking pervert.
Even back then there was a line,
there was a line in love if there was a
line in love and death.
Remember loving death?
Yes.
And Diane Keaton goes to this high
priest and she steps on his beard and
it's very funny scene and he says the
most beautiful thing in the world is a
12 year old girl,
blonde hair,
preferably twins,
right?
And this is all this perverted.
The thing is,
this happened 20 years,
25 before he got accused of anything,
you know,
but it was just interesting hearing
because he did a couple of.
He did it even in Manhattan with
Hemingway was a little bit,
little bit twisted,
you know,
I don't remember Manhattan very much.
Well,
he falls in love and she pulls a love
with him.
She's supposed to be 16 and he's Jesus
Christ.
Yeah.
Well it's not something that people tend
to do.
They try to normalize whatever fucked up
provision they have and they put it into
art.
Like that was one of the things that
they were accusing Louis Ck of with this
movie that he released right before it
came out that he was jerking off in
front of a bunch of metal.
The had this movie and part of the movie
was just talking about how everyone's a
pervert.
We're all perverts.
I'll tell you something off the air.
Okay.
Can we get off?
Remind me to tell you.
I don't want to say off the with dom.
I rare.
That's your new show off the air with
Dom Irrera burn people and any context
had,
hey,
is this thing on?
It's not good.
Let me tell you a story.
I got to go actually,
the night that he was,
or the day after he went,
I went on stage.
I got.
I said,
I'm so excited.
I got a part in a Louis ck new TV show.
Should shoot in about 10,
15 years and it took them a beat and
then they got it.
I think he'll be back in a year.
Well,
you know what Joe,
he has that advantage of.
He was the one that created the idea of
selling your own thing.
Right.
So he can do that.
He doesn't need a producer for that.
That's true.
You'd have him on this show,
right?
I would.
One hundred percent of them on.
Yeah.
I think he's a different person than
when he did those things.
I think those things that he did jerking
off in front of him punch people's
terrible and I think he probably had an
idea in his head of what those things
were and of who he was and who he would
be.
And I think a lot of your self
definitions a lot of times are based on
this very limited idea of who you are.
Very limited idea of who you're going to
be and he's like a wallowing in his own
weirdness and just wants a jerk off in
front of somebody,
you know,
it's out of all the offenses of things
you could do to someone.
It's one of the least egregious because
he's not raping.
He's not as.
He didn't lock the door.
He's not.
Yeah,
he didn't lock the door.
He's not doing anything awful to
someone.
He just doing something weird in front
of them.
I think it's beautiful to,
you know,
I don't think it's beautiful because a
lot of things that I think of you to
think it's a plus.
It's definitely a black.
Well,
it's,
it's human.
Like
then I bet at it out of the air because
of an ape doesn't really care if you
jerk and if you're watching when he's
jerking off,
it could be the jerky over the banana
and one hand banana and the other.
Get it.
Hey,
hey,
hey.
Yeah.
I'm at all the things that he did and I
think that his apology pretty was what's
a way to look at it?
Um,
I think it honest and I think it sort of
explained how his mind worked and why he
did it in the first place.
It's not,
it's obviously not something you're
proud of.
So obviously something he's disgusted by
himself and you can't.
Here's the thing,
you jerk off in front of someone 10
years ago.
How do you fix that?
You don't do it again.
He hasn't done it again.
Here's the thing.
No one's saying these done anything in a
long time.
Like all the accusations were like,
I want to say they were from there or
from years ago.
Right.
What do you do?
Like how do you fix that clicks?
Let's say you did jerk off in front of a
few people.
Dom,
like,
you know,
I don't know why that came up for the
blind lady is,
is it still killed?
It depends on how good are hearing is.
Oh,
she's here.
She's like,
why are you doing over there at dawn?
And she has to guess.
It's all fucking guesswork.
What do you,
how do you fix that?
Like what does a guy do to fix that?
I mean,
I think out of all the people,
like how the fuck would you rehabilitate
Harvey Weinstein?
How do you let Harvey Weinstein around a
woman again,
how do you,
how do you leave Harvey Weinstein in a
hotel room with a woman who comes in for
a meeting or it was the worst.
He's the worst.
He's the word.
I don't think you can rehabilitate to
him.
What do you do?
How do you,
how do you,
uh,
how do you fix that?
The only way cosby gets rehabilitated,
um,
I mean not really rehabilitated,
but the only way he gets reintroduced
into society is if everyone believes
those girls are lying and that's never
going to happen.
It's impossible because everybody heard
those stories a long time ago when I did
star search and like 83 and he was the
guest host and we were hearing shit
about him on the set.
Then really womanizing and stuff.
Yeah.
I mean Chris,
not as extreme as a drug and drug and
raping them.
But like if you're a guy like Louis,
c,
k,
how do you,
what do you do?
Like what would he,
what could he have done before the story
came out that he's doing that to girls?
What,
what could he have done to make amends?
I mean,
what could you have done?
He said sorry to some of the people.
I don't know why you looking at me like
that.
I'm just trying to think.
I'm just trying to.
You're my friend.
I'm looking at you and you're right
there.
I'm just thinking like what would one
do?
I mean it seems like let's.
I mean I'm not exonerating him.
Right?
But it seems like all these years since
then he hasn't done it again.
Right.
So if he hasn't done it again,
he must understand that there's
something wrong with it.
There's some weird compulsion and it had
to be a power thing because anybody can
get a hooker and do that.
No.
Well here's the thing.
He was probably doing that too.
Yeah,
I mean it'd be like jerking off in front
of people.
He might've just like jerking off in
front of all kinds of people.
He might've jerked off in front of
hookers to.
I mean,
I don't know,
but we know that he did it in front of
women that really didn't want them to do
that.
That's what I thought might be part of
the kinkiness,
but
there's some stories of him doing it in
front of women and they thought it was
hilarious.
He did it in front of some female comics
and they thought it was hilarious.
How do you stay hard when they're
laughing?
You've got to be a real animal.
It's better than better man than me.
Dumb.
I did a lot.
Just.
I don't know what you think of this
line,
but I.
Woody Allen said that mentioned on stage
in these women started bowing.
I said,
why you boom?
They said because of what he did and the
daughter and all this.
I said,
look,
I didn't know.
I said,
but the one thing you got to admit,
he really must love her because it's not
like she's hot,
but that got a laugh.
When we get offstage.
I'll tell you one,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
snoop bit.
I can't say it on stage,
but I'll tell you on stage when you tell
me your thing onstage with Tony
Hinchcliffe has a new bit that's fucking
ruthless and killed me and we came up
with it in the car this weekend.
We're on a road trip and we were talking
about something and he said it and I
fucking died.
I say,
you got to say that onstage.
He goes,
seriously?
I go,
got to say that on stage,
and he did it last night in the room.
Fucking exploded.
You had to come back and do the show and
I do.
It would show his show killed Tony.
I don't like to work Monday nights.
Oh yeah.
Well you got to have a schedule now.
You got to see the family,
but I have a scheduled now on Monday,
Sunday to Monday,
Sunday and was Sundays and Mondays is
extreme family time.
I just don't do Jack Shit because you
won't have these days and they grow up
so fast.
Not to get corny,
but it's true.
Yeah,
it's true.
I'm,
I'm enjoying it.
I'm.
I'm happier now than I've ever been in
my life.
Good.
That's great to hear that.
Yeah,
and I'm also,
I think I'm a nicer person now that I've
ever been in my life.
Wait a little bit,
way nicer.
Huge,
much to compare with his little brick.
What did you think?
It just makes you a,
you know,
Dave Chappelle said this to me once and
I think it was a really great quote.
He said not only is having children made
me,
um,
made me love someone more than I ever
thought I could.
It's changed my capacity for love and
that's cool.
Yeah,
he's like my capacity for love as much
greater than it.
That make sense.
Like you realize like a lot of our
struggles and a lot of the shit that we,
we go through in this life,
it's a lot of it is about perspective
and a lot of it is about who's around
you and what kind of loving environment
you around.
And it's also having kids and not having
the strain,
the financial strain,
the emotional strain and the ignorance
strain that my parents had.
Their parents are like,
ignorance is a big thing too.
Like they didn't know how to raise kids
back then.
Of course they hit us,
they,
you know,
they yelled at us and they didn't know
me.
My mom didn't hit me,
but you know,
it was a common thing for people hit
their kids.
I remember Bruce Willis said to me one
time to be a named driver.
He said,
you know,
one of the things about having kids,
he goes,
there's a little girl,
I forget the middle little one's name.
He said she would wake me up to walk her
to the bathroom and,
and,
and to her I wasn't a movie star wasn't
any,
I was daddy because she's afraid of the
dark.
Walking her in and he said that really
humanized them and made them feel good
because you know,
it's like you get stroked all the time.
It's like sometimes you just want to be
normal.
Well,
not only that,
when Bruce Willis was famous,
there was way less famous people because
there was no famous internet
personalities.
There was no famous reality TV stars.
There was way less famous rappers and
there was way less famous comedians
think out.
A few famous Comedians,
they were like me and dice and guys that
were on Rodney specials.
We were really fucking lucky because we
became instant draws.
I paid to see you after you were on
Rodney.
Special extra.
Yeah.
I went to see you at next and I went to
see two nights in a row because one
night I thought you were supposed to be
there and neither you missed your flight
or something happened and Dennis leary
was there instead.
And I was like,
what the fuck?
So we came back the next day and we saw
you again.
But I'm really with a girl that I was
dating.
Her name was Stephanie.
She was,
uh,
she's telling me what to do.
She was older,
really the dominant one.
She was,
it was the first girl.
She was 25.
I was 21.
She's sick.
She liked the deck though to tell you
that woo.
Like it would be a little.
The old lesbian.
Well that was.
What was exciting about it.
She's the first woman I dated,
like,
you know,
she was a woman that I dated girls
before that,
that girl was a woman and you know,
she was fucking smart to refer girls who
are a woman's age.
Yeah,
she was.
I'm too intense.
She tells me what to do with standup up
to me.
A Standard Bailey's.
Yeah.
It's of hilarious.
So that Seinfeld episode where the girl
broke up with him because of his act
funny.
And she goes,
uh,
I don't think this is going to work.
He goes,
are,
we're having a great time.
She says,
well,
your act with the Igg ever notice?
She goes,
that's not my style of comedy.
He goes,
you're breaking up with me because on my
ass.
She goes,
yes,
I am as the end.
That's hilarious.
Well,
if you were a girl and you were a huge
comedy fan,
I could imagine if you were a girl and
you just,
you love Chappelle and pill burden and
dom irrera and Duncan trussell and Joey
Diaz and all these great comedians,
and then you start dating a prop act
anyway,
and he's the worst prop act.
Yeah.
It's like fucking stupid.
He's got a soundtrack,
he has to play,
hit the music,
fucking dropped down and comes up with
an album jokes and sophie told me that
she would,
she couldn't go out with me if she
didn't like my.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
If you're a comedy fan of me,
if you're a music fan,
how the fuck would you date a guy who's
got terrible songs?
Yeah.
How could you be brought,
you know,
if you're a,
a bad accountant,
you know,
but you're a great guy.
Probably still get a date.
You know what,
if you're a fucking terrible to thing
that someone loves.
Right.
Well that's so much more personal than
the debits and credits.
You know,
it's like you're standing up as you are
a reflection of you generally.
I mean,
if a good shit good stand up is one of
the most personal things.
I think music stand up.
Maybe writing.
Writing's pretty personal.
Yeah.
But stand up really good ups or reveal
something of themselves.
You feel like you know them for
something to relate to the brochure.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
I mean there's more famous standups
today.
I was talking with Jeff Wills from a lot
and I know Jeff.
Yeah.
Jeff and I were talking about the number
of guys today and gals that can sell out
big ass theaters and it's nuts.
He's like,
dude,
20 years ago there was nobody,
there was like a handful.
Everybody worked at clubs and there was
a few George Carlin's out there,
you know,
a few Chris Rock's or whoever it was at
the time that could sell out a theater
and now like,
fucking everybody's selling out these
theaters.
It's crazy.
They have the right social media,
social media.
Um,
but they still have to have an act
because they'll sell out once,
maybe twice,
but then then it's done.
I what have one,
a lot of those people from that.
Let's stand up.
Competition show.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
last comic standing.
Yeah.
They went around once than the ones that
were good.
Like Alonzo Bowden.
Eliza.
Eliza is probably the most successful
out of that group.
Yeah,
she's done more.
I think she's had more specials.
She'd see sells out everywhere.
She does.
Good size theaters,
she's selling out or she just sold out
our whole tour.
She probably has the most success.
She works hard.
She does work hard.
That girl kicks ass like she doesn't
fuck around.
She told me something so funny when she
was on my podcast and have you heard
this?
When Jamie still did it and she goes,
I have a great body,
you know,
kits with sweatpants.
So I don't think it will.
I know.
I don't know.
She didn't show it for God's sakes.
Wear a skirt.
I Dunno.
And she'd tell you you're some piece of
shit for asking to show,
but I don't know what to tell her.
Like,
you know,
well she's funny.
She's,
she's an aggressive girl.
When she was on my podcast,
it's the fucking comments were
hilarious.
Like men either love her or they fucking
hate her.
Like I've heard the thumbs up,
the thumbs down versus Eliza,
like I'm on the podcast have thumbs up,
thumbs down.
She got like one of the worst ratios of
any button that's ever been on the
podcast.
Really?
Yeah.
I enjoyed it.
I enjoyed talking to her.
I like her.
I'm not threatened by confident.
I would say cocky women doesn't threaten
me,
but for a lot because I'm not threatened
by confident,
cocky man.
I'm around them all the time.
Of course it doesn't bother me.
I don't judge you by it.
I maybe I feel like it's silly sometimes
with some people if they're too
confident,
too cocky or they're too dismissive of
other people.
I think it's silly,
but I don't get mad at it.
I would have when I was younger,
when I was younger,
uh,
someone that was like cocky or
overconfident or just,
you know,
just I would just feel threatened by it
or be upset by it or a judge them,
you know,
in a weird way to connect all my own
shit to them get upset at them.
Yeah,
I know what you mean.
I know.
I definitely,
I definitely have trouble with attitude
thinking,
you know,
lucky or,
lucky we are to be in this fucking
money.
It looks like to work.
Well,
one of the things about you,
dom,
you're always super supportive of young
guys and girls to.
You've always been like real supportive
of,
uh,
you know,
I think you should be,
I think so too.
I've learned a lot of that from you.
Oh,
cool man.
Let's thinking about tiffany because
tiffany means a lot to me.
You know,
I taught her at a comedy camp when she
was a teenager and I've seen it.
I've seen it through a bunch of
struggles,
you know,
crazy lost their homes and she kept
trying to keep her family together.
So I had another podcast and she said,
you know,
she was sent back in the day.
She goes,
I wanted to fuck you.
I said,
first of all,
tiffany,
you like a god daughter to me.
It never crossed my mind and it really
didn't even know.
I think she's a beautiful girl.
And I said,
the second thing is I never take my
pants in front of you.
I said,
no,
this is beautiful black girl going,
you call it added Dick.
That's my biggest fear.
It's funny watching her blow up.
She's hilarious.
And she took to it like a duck to water
men like immediately confidence.
Oh,
she's got massive confidence,
but immediately,
like,
almost like she feels like that's where
she was always meant to be.
Oh,
because he's just waiting for the bell
to ring.
No,
when she did call bare,
honest to God,
I'm sitting there crying.
I swear finding happiness.
So that's awesome.
The jealousy.
I was catching it on the show and I,
I love cold bear.
He doesn't even return my call.
I've got trump jokes too.
It's all that show is these days.
Right?
I don't think it'd be on the airports if
trump.
It would be on the air.
I don't know.
Joe.
They were dying.
They were,
they were way behind the Nielsen ratings
all of a sudden,
but they were behind.
Right.
Are Way behind.
Then he went for it.
Yeah.
When he called the president's mouth
Putin's cock holster.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I can't believe he said that on the
head.
You didn't hear that?
No.
He went on this epic rant about trump
and then,
uh,
he said something about his mouth being
Putin's cock holster.
And I just.
And they beeped out cock,
obviously pretty obvious what he said,
but I'm sitting there going,
what is going on with late night tv?
Well,
I kimball's been on a run lately,
uh,
crying and crying.
I think it breaks down like every night
now.
It's really good for ratings.
He's a sensitive guy.
Good way to cut to commercial.
He's a legitimately sensitive guy.
Very nice guy.
Like Jimmy Kimmel is a very,
very good person.
I key.
He's a genuine,
nice guy with a real heart in it really
does care.
You know.
I remember he cried after the Vegas
Shooting and he's from Vegas.
Did he cry recently?
Was it the school shooting?
But that was brutal though.
She's fucking,
the Shit I go out with was there that
night and she was at the trop and then
all the people came running down into
the truck.
So New Year's Eve.
I'm with Vegas shooter.
Yeah.
People,
they had to stay there for hours.
They had everything under lock down
because they didn't know who had guns
and who didn't.
They didn't know it with one person or
50 people.
And she's there.
She's at the trop and uh,
she got kind of traumatized by it,
so new year's Eve were walking outside
and all of a sudden she starts shaking
and she was having an anxiety attack,
you know,
about being in a crowd.
So I was just fucking,
we're trying to make her laugh and say
don't worry about it.
And then we're in the fireworks.
That's all I really care about is
fireworks.
And he took that away from me because
you're selfish and Felix,
you know,
but,
but I got her laugh in any way.
The fucking,
the,
the volume of them.
It's just,
it seems like every couple months or
some new one.
Remember when Columbine,
we thought this is terrible.
It's won't happen again.
Again.
It's like there's so many now,
you know,
you get used to it,
which has said,
yeah,
it's fucking crazy.
And I don't know what the answer is.
You know,
I don't know if it's a tighter gun
control.
I don't know if that would stop them
because it would just make it more
difficult to get guns,
but would that be enough?
But we're not doing anything.
Well,
the interesting thing to try something,
I don't know what to do.
I'm in and there's also the number of
people that are on psychiatric
medication.
It's fucking crazy.
Well,
I think that for the [inaudible] or
whatever they are,
they share sold.
They shouldn't be.
I mean,
we really need that to kill a pheasant.
It's not a a hunting gun really.
You're the guy who designed them,
said he made it for war.
Yeah.
The real real
for hunting are usually usually bolt
action rifles,
which means you have around.
You have usually two or three in the
magazine.
You have a couple or one in the chamber.
You put it in there,
cheeky,
lock it in place.
The clamp it down and you fire a shot
and then you have to bolted again.
You have to use the.
The action again.
The shell pops out and another one goes
in,
bolt that down,
and then you get another shot.
It's a very slow thing.
It takes a couple of Musket,
whereas these are like tack,
tack,
tack tack,
or with the bump stocks.
They apparently,
the president wants a ban bump stocks
with a bump.
Stock is,
Oh yeah,
it's a stock where you pull back on it
and apparently you push forward and pull
back at the same time.
Uh,
I might be fucking this up,
but the thing is the stock makes the
trigger go like that,
that,
where it's almost like an automatic
weapon and trump just decided to ban
those.
And there's a lot of people that are up
in arms about him banning those,
like these,
the gun rights people don't want to lose
anything.
They don't want to lose any rights.
They don't want to lose any fucking
crazy ass weapons.
They think that any slip is a,
is eventually going to lead to them
getting their guns taken away.
Like I follow a bunch of NRA people and
gun people on twitter and instagram and
take their guns away.
They think they are.
I mean,
I agree with you.
I don't think that's ever going to come
to that.
But the idea that tighter regulation is
bad.
I don't think that's true.
I think,
uh,
I think first of all you should have to
go through some sort of examination.
If you can go through exam,
you don't,
you can't drive a fucking car unless you
prove that you know how to operate a
car.
Like someone has to be there with you.
That's an expert.
So driving expert watches you,
they watch.
Make sure you know what to do.
What do you do here at this light?
Do you know how to hit the brakes?
Do stop perfectly.
Do you look left and right before you
turn all that shit is super important.
If you want to drive,
how the fuck is it?
Not Super Important.
If you operate a goddamn firearm,
I know I don't understand like the kid
who bought the,
I think the kid who did the,
uh,
latest shooting in Florida,
I think it was two stories together.
I don't know,
but apparently he was under age and had
fake id and still was able to buy it.
I don't know,
I didn't read that story.
That'd be,
you know,
I avoided the story.
I saw the kid's face and I saw the,
it's fucking insane.
And you hear all the stories about kids
that were saying that they knew that
this kid was going to be a school
shooter anyway,
they were saying in the past.
And then one of the things he wrote it,
wrote it on facebook or something that
he wants to be a professional school
shooter.
And then two years later and he got
visited by the FBI,
the FBI actually checked this fucking
kid out.
Talk to him about it,
decided he wasn't a threat.
How do you decide someone's a threat or
not a threat?
Well,
if you're talking to them,
they were a threat.
I mean,
they may be.
I can't talk to everybody,
but I would be suspicious of anyone that
it took that much energy to go find it.
How did they find them?
Why would they,
why would they even question them?
Um,
I think people were saying that he's a
fucking psychopath.
It hurts.
It's just sad.
It's just fucking sad that it's sad that
anyone could do that.
It's sad that anyone would be hurting
and so fucked up that you can take a
child.
Imagine you have a kid,
right?
You got a little dom,
irrera,
little tiny baby and he's just a cute
little fellow,
little tiny baby and they don't know
anything that would tickle him and then
from there one day that becomes a school
shooter.
That's what people have to take into
consideration that this boy,
this 19 year old boy who did that was a
baby at one point in time.
He's a failed process of failed product,
whether it's through his environment,
his family,
his DNA,
all the above,
his life experiences,
all the pain,
the trauma,
mental illness,
all these various factors,
but
that used to be a baby.
Probably the cutest little fucker
probably hold them and cuddle and we'd
go to sleep in your arms and one of the
things is changed with me since and it
changes a little bit every day.
I feel like every day I just get a
little bit more compassionate and more
understanding and I work towards it.
It's something I really think about,
but having children,
I think of people as they used to be a
child,
he has to be a baby.
I think of that with the homeless people
in there and they're all those blankets
and stuff.
I think this was born at.
This person was born into somebody.
Yeah.
No,
I was thinking that the other day I was
at coffee bean and I knew homeless guy
was there from the smell that was
pouring cream in my coffee.
I witnessed,
smelled them jail.
He wouldn't have.
Right.
You were just talking about the hit
before the podcast.
Your sense of smell is no good.
So good.
Anyway,
the guy smelled so bad that,
um,
he was dressed fairly normal.
He wasn't disgustingly dressed.
I had to look at them to,
to,
to recognize like,
oh,
this guy's homeless.
I looked over and he just fucking stunk.
It was rough.
I mean he just stunk and I looked over
and the guy sitting there with his head
in his hands like this,
like he's probably just full of terrible
anxiety or thoughts or depression or
whatever it was,
but all I was thinking that important
cream in my coffee.
It's like that when someone's a little
boy,
I know someone's a little boy and now
here he is.
He looks like he's in his sixties and
he's all fucked up and smells like shit.
He's sitting there and this coffee bean
and he's sitting by himself with his
head in his hands and everyone's
avoiding him.
I'll just moving around him and yeah,
if you think of life like that,
they think of people like that.
It's easier to be humanized.
Yes.
I like we were talking about Louis and
nothing like Louis again,
but this kid that was working the
brokerage and a in Long Island and he
comes in with his mom to see me and he
said,
I don't think what Louis did was that
bad.
They didn't rape her or anything.
I said,
well,
it would be better if he did it to your
sister.
He goes,
I'd fucking kill him.
I said,
well,
that should tell you something that you
shouldn't kill him for that,
but you know,
it bothers you enough.
That's somebody else's sister know.
And you know,
Louis apologized and I'm not trying to
jump on him again,
but I mean you got to know how you'd
feel about it when it was personal.
Yeah.
Well,
the Louis One's so weird.
It's very weird.
So we're just.
Whenever it's not like you're with
someone and you're making out and you
pull your dick out and she grabs it and
not getting hard over here.
I mean this is,
this is not the.
Not In the act of intimacy.
It's just touching.
There's nothing.
Not even verbal abuse.
The only touch with yourself.
Maybe there's oral abuse,
like as in sound like maybe you made
weird noises.
You make that face to camera.
I wonder how many people make a ric
flair when they come?
What's that?
You know when Rick Flair.
Woo.
Do you remember Rick Flair?
You're talking to the Rolex wearing
diamond rank?
Wearing jet flying.
Oh,
he's the limousine riding.
He's a fighter.
No,
he's a pro wrestler.
Oh,
that's what I meant.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's fucking just.
He is a.
he's an American iconic character.
Not just a progress,
like an American icon icon,
but Tuesday where I'll talk about rick
flare onstage and point the microphone
and the audience and the audience just
goes,
who is the nature boy?
Ric flair.
I don't remember him.
Who is the guy that Mohammed Ali,
he modeled his.
Was a gorgeous George.
He modeled his.
Yeah,
he gave credit to this guy that's
professional wrestler.
Oh,
no kidding.
That's interesting.
I think it was gorgeous.
George couldn't be.
There was a lot of those guys back then.
Remember you remember killer Kowalski?
Abraham?
Yes.
The claw.
Grab your head.
Remember who was the one that cocoa but
the Bobo Bobo,
Brazil,
Brazil to the.
Uh,
and uh,
there was a Bruno San Martino Martino.
Interesting.
It was a world champion.
How Mohammed Ali's fascination with
progressing fueled his career inspired
mma.
Interesting.
Gorgeous.
George was crazy.
Was Gorgeous.
George.
Interesting was the stupid ad you have
to watch for the Olympics there.
Boy,
I'm.
This Olympics is.
I think I'm going to say this.
I think the Olympics are gross.
This is why I think the Olympics are
gross.
I think it's a great opportunity for all
those athletes.
I think it's great for people to watch
it,
but I think it is a fucking disgusting
money grab and all those amateur air
quotes.
Athletes don't get paid shit.
And these companies are making billions
and billions of dollars off of them and
I really wish they would all quit.
I really wish they would say,
fuck you pay me.
I really wish they would just go
straight ray Liotta they give you pain.
Me,
they get up there.
They're youth for that.
Not only that,
the fucking companies,
they're so restrictive,
the IOC and all the people that are
behind it are so restrictive and they
are making ungodly sums of money,
ungodly contracts.
They're just giant contracts to air the
the Olympics.
Giant amounts of money to build these
stadiums and set up these are these
events and that everything is about net
nationalism and national pride.
Whether it's in Korea or Russia or
wherever the fuck they do them.
But meanwhile the athletes don't get
dick.
They don't get Dick.
If you're lucky and you're Michael
Phelps,
he become famous out of it and you get a
bunch of commercials,
commercials and endorsements and you
make a shit load of money that way.
But how many Michael Phelps is are there
was a three or four.
I mean how many,
but how many in the.
All the.
All the Olympics in adult.
All the Olympics.
Jamie,
you're a sports fan and all the
Olympics.
Say like the Olympics this year.
Well,
let's go the last one.
Who the fuck came out of it?
Where they're a household name right now
you've got shaun white and maybe I heard
of that guy.
That girl that won.
Kim is her last name is the border
bronze last night or two nights before
the real famous.
There's Lindsey Vonn.
She's very famous.
She's very famous and she.
She used to date tiger woods that made
her famous two plus.
She's hot.
That makes her famous shit.
Interesting names.
So I helped her.
She was a gold medal winner I believe.
How many other ones are there?
So few.
I mean it's just like a handful.
They can build a story around someone
then they can sell the story,
but.
But when you get to the point where it's
worthwhile to sacrifice your entire life
and it actually pays off,
what are the,
what are the odds?
It's so fucking small,
but meanwhile people are tuning in to
all of it,
the making massive amounts of revenue
from all of it and they're not sharing
it with the athletes at all.
I think it's fucking gross.
They pretend it's amateur.
The tenants and amateur.
It's a Goddamn motherfucking business.
That's what the Olympics are.
Sensible college business.
You can't basketball and football.
Really?
NCAA says student athletes shouldn't be
paid because the 13th amendment allows
unpaid prison labor.
What the fuck?
Oh,
that's Shaun King.
This is a.
This is another article.
Well,
the main one going around,
but there's a.
that's crazy.
Didn't really say that.
Did they really say that?
The 13th amendment which allows unpaid
prison labor decided in a lawsuit,
a response to a motion to dismiss.
That's what they use is.
It's so disgusting.
They're so disgusting.
They're the same to me.
Ncaa College football and basketball.
Same thing to me.
They have 100,000 people.
Yeah,
fuck you pay those guys,
pay them,
pay those girls,
pay all those athletes.
You're making money.
You're making money and you're not
sharing it with the athletes.
They might as well be slaves.
They might as well be fucking prisoners,
the Olympics,
Ncaa,
all that shit.
It's just these.
No Way.
There's no way you could do that fresh
today if you started from scratch today.
Instead we're going to go make billions
of dollars and we're gonna give you,
Uhm,
got gunshow ghoul.
There's no way you could never do
occasion.
Imagine if they did that with the
Olympics today.
They said,
look,
we're going to spend billions of dollars
and the athletes,
what are they going to pay?
Oh,
we're not going to pay them shit.
They don't get anything.
You're making any money.
You're fucked.
You're out.
I used to be that you made money.
But now they let basketball players play
in the Olympics.
They liked the NBA players because I
think it was Russia was,
was getting close and beat and they beat
us once 72 I think.
Oh,
is that what it was?
They started thinking about it.
Then when they were,
they were catching up,
the European players were catching up.
They go,
fuck this.
We're going to send over a brother's.
NBC Sports is about to make one point
$4,000,000,000 in 22 days thanks to
super superbowl in the limiter Olympics.
Okay.
The superbowl,
at least his professional athletes,
I get paid.
They get paid.
Whether they get paid enough is up for
debate.
I get that.
But the Olympics,
they're not getting paid dick and it's
fucking gross and it makes me angry and
it's one of the reasons why I don't
watch the Olympics.
I get mad at it.
You know,
I wanted to be in the Olympics at one
point in time to play.
I wanted to be in the back window.
Was being introduced the Olympics in
1988.
I tried out for the national team.
I got into like the quarter finals in
Miami.
I won three fights and it was,
um,
that was the last,
like my,
my last,
uh,
my really last fascination with
taekwondo had kind of given up on
taekwondo.
Really before it,
I'd started kickboxing ready and I
realized the limitations of taekwondo.
What is that?
The,
the hands punching to the face.
Taekwondo window.
You don't punch the face.
He punched the body and you kick to the
face and kick to the body,
which is the.
Yeah,
it's a very different thing because it's
so easy to punch someone in the face
comparatively and so hard to kick
someone in the face,
so the,
the dexterity of the legs,
like for people that know how to kick,
it's just you develop much more leg
dexterity and you get way better at
kicking and moving your legs,
but as soon as you fight a good boxer,
you realize how poor the.
Like the balances between your hands and
your feet and I had a really develop my
hand techniques and so I was really
concentrating on boxing at that point in
my life.
Like really learning how to box and
learning how to punch correctly and
learning how to put kicks together with
punches because you just.
There's a bunch of stuff that you can
get away with if someone's not punching
you in the face that you can't get away
with.
As soon as they start doing it.
And I was already kind of disillusioned
because I was learning.
I was just learning that.
It was a very flawed and then I started
doing more tie with leg kicks and I
realized like when Jesus Christ,
like as soon as you kick the legs like
this,
most of this shit's out the window.
Right?
It changes.
What's a,
what you can and can't get away with.
What do you think is the most lethal
martial arts,
the best martial art to learn for
someone for self defense or even plating
them,
put them in the fight.
It's hard to beat wrestling because
wrestling you dictate whether or not the
fight stays or goes to the ground.
We're wrestling is like,
in my opinion,
the best base,
but once you.
Once you've passed that,
then it's about submissions,
so it's wrestling and then submissions
because if a guy has wrestling,
he can take you to the ground and punch
in the face and stuff like that,
but if the guy on the bottom is good at
Jujitsu,
he might still be able to submit you
like the early ufc days hoists gracie
submitted much larger people like Dan
Severn off of his back and Dan Severn
was a real world class wrestler at the
time and the hoists submitted them off
his back with a Jujitsu because he
didn't know Jujitsu,
so I think wrestling,
the ability to take someone down,
it's probably number one,
but Jujitsu is a very close second
because the problem with Jujitsu is if a
guy knows how to wrestle really good and
he can keep you standing up,
if he's better at punching and kicking,
he could fuck you up standing up and
you'll never get the fight to the ground
to use your Jujitsu because his
wrestling could also keep the fight
standing.
The wrestling dictates where the fight
takes place.
That to me is the most critical thing
like you have.
If you're a wrestle,
you have the ability to take someone
down,
you have the ability to stand up and you
have to ability to keep someone from
taking you down.
Those are,
those are giant like that.
To be able to choose where the fight
takes place is giant.
That's cool.
But when I was doing taekwondo,
there was really no mma.
No one had ever even invented it.
I stopped fighting and 88,
I think 88 or 89.
I'm not exactly sure.
I was doing comedy at the time too.
When did you say we met?
We met in [inaudible] 93,
I think,
or [inaudible] 92 might have been
[inaudible] 92.
So it was probably with Kim at the time.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
I was done fighting then I was done,
but I was still thinking about it.
I was still thinking about it for years,
you know,
if everything went wrong,
call me,
fell apart for me.
Maybe I'd take a fight,
you know.
When did you know the comedy wasn't
going to pull up?
A couple weeks ago.
Two weeks.
I was driving one of my car,
I was driving my car over to the other
car,
white workout,
sell all this.
Just live modestly.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
Uh,
I,
its really.
I've written,
I really didn't think I was gonna work
out until I was on tv,
you know,
men.
I was like,
Hey,
this might be all right.
Yeah.
But that's a good thing though,
that not knowing if it's gonna work out.
It's what keeps you hungry.
I think the worst thing in life could
ever happen and she's getting an
inheritance.
GotTa texts the incentive away.
Huh?
Why?
Yeah.
You're not scared.
You're not scared about the future.
You're not scared about what the fuck's
going to happen.
You have to have that feeling of not
knowing is awesome.
I mean that,
that feeling creates movement and
anxiety and energy.
Like some of my best sets I've ever had
in my,
the biggest jumps I've ever had in my
life and my career have been after I had
terrible sets and some of my best
moments in life as a person have been
after I felt terrible.
Like after I just fuck something up or I
did something stupid and I just like,
how can I do that?
Like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
And then you feel like shit for a few
days and then you emerge out of it like
a phoenix from the ashes and you,
you're a better person because of that
bad feeling.
Like those bad moments,
like don't just drowned them out,
don't take pills,
don't,
don't just drowned them out.
Sometimes those bad moments are an
incentive for you to move forward and
progress.
I remember when I did the tonight show
the first time,
it was not fun because it was like the
imprimatur.
Who's like Johnny Carson?
It was like a WHO's that?
Like it was terrifying.
I wonder to run into the woods in
Burbank,
Burbank and start a new life.
I swear to God.
I just,
I was so fucking patch of woods.
I was scared.
Yeah,
I know.
But a tent from the street.
You know what I did Joe after?
After my shirt.
What went?
Did a set at the comedy store.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
I just wanted to see the juxtaposition
of the two and must've felt good.
Oh fuck.
Great.
Just to be back on my turf,
you know,
because that wasn't my turf.
They said Teddy bears.
Ron Did that.
Do you remember?
Teddy bears?
Ron Clark Academy store.
Let me tell you this,
folks.
I don't know if I've said this before.
I probably have because I'm repetitive
fuckhead,
but Teddy Burger on at one point in time
was one of the greatest comics that ever
lived.
He was fucking incredible.
And he did it tonight show set and he
got on the piano and he was like singing
on the piano and talking on the piano
and it was magical,
magical.
And they said he went to the comedy
store that night,
got fucked out of his head and was
stumbling into the streets and just out
of his mind just had a problem with
substances.
Yeah,
I know.
I remember he was so drunk that we were
at a club in Long Island and he sat on
the edge of the stage and started crying
and the audience thought that he was
fucking around.
So they all started laughing.
Oh my God,
can you imagine?
So that's hilarious.
And by the way,
his is set on the tonight show.
This is what I was told.
He did so much overtime that they had
the bump somebody and that's why he went
to the couch.
Wasn't he went to the couch because it
was so great.
It was.
And he never did the show again as far
as I know.
But he never did the show again because
he fucked something up.
I think he got drunk and he did this.
He did way too much time.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
but they loved him.
Like johnny was loving him,
like how could he not?
Johnny.
Johnny was very supportive of mostly
everybody you know.
So he was,
I mean he was the greatest.
Didn't Howard stern hate Johnny Carson
though?
Did he really?
I think he did.
I think he hated him.
Like I remember him talking about Johnny
Carson being a terrible person,
a piece of shit.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure.
I hope I'm not wrong with that.
The most nervous I ever got ever for
doing anything was doing stern.
Yeah.
I was terrified because you wanted to
see was an idol of mine.
I mean for me,
he was um,
he was my generation's Johnny Carson.
Yeah.
Because I didn't give a fuck about being
on the tonight show.
To me I was,
I was a dirty comic.
I cared about.
I never thought I'd be on the show.
Yeah.
I like,
I like guys like Hicks and Kennison and
dice and,
and prior and that's not that tonight.
Show stuff was great.
I enjoyed watching like Jenny on.
Are you on or someone who's that?
Who could do that style and do it really
well though it was really hard for me.
I'd rather do Improv but used to do it
well.
You were great on those shows.
I tried,
but it's not you like at the comedy
store killing?
No,
it's a different thing.
It's a different thing.
This was never attracted to it.
Just to me,
the five minutes,
the censorship,
the,
all this stuff is just like it.
It didn't mean anything to me.
I always think the coolest thing about
your career is you did what you wanted
to do.
I mean,
you basically,
you did a sitcom.
He did like liquid through the career
you have now.
I mean like it's only you in that lane.
You know what I mean?
It's bizarre.
I don't know that you did you do this
announcing jobs and it's like,
dude,
could be just that and you're already a
success,
but you got to stand up.
You got anything you want,
you know?
Well,
yeah.
It's just like you said,
it's just things I enjoy God.
I'm lucky that there's things that I
enjoy that our jobs,
yeah,
lucrative,
but it's always a good thing.
But the night before I did start for the
first time I was shitting my pants.
Never.
I would never thought that nervous as
fuck because it was,
to me it was like,
I can't even believe I'm really going to
do is show to me.
Like if they told me I was going to do
tonight show,
I'd be like,
alright,
I'll do it.
Like I would have been a nervous.
I would have been.
Would you do it now?
No,
no,
I don't want to.
I was know.
Well you could do is lose.
It's better than can you can when you
have a good set and fun and everything
like that.
But,
but you're expected to have it.
Say.
Well it's just.
I talked too much.
I talked to.
I talked too much already.
I've talked too much so far.
I want to go.
Let's go play pool.
Let's wrap this fucker up.
Dominic.
Let's do it.
Let's,
I'll shoot a couple of games.
let's wrap this up and go play pool of
the extra anytime.
My brother anytime.
Where can people see you?
You got some dates coming up next week.
I'm at the,
a black box and a Boca Raton and then
the following week,
admit a brand's club stress factory in
New Jersey.
Awesome club.
And then the uh,
the Improv,
but Vegas and first week of April and
all of a sudden your website.
I don't know who maintains your website.
Some guy who's a fan of mine.
He's a great guy.
This Guy David.
Dave,
tell us a [inaudible] dot com.
They have a calendar up there.
How the fuck do people find out where
your gigs are?
I try to keep a secret.
I don't want to be bothered by crowds.
Ladies and gentlemen,
go play some pool.